à dijon aux assises de la côte-d'or
christine villemin fait figure d'accusée
il faut dire qu'à la barre des témoins
de nouveaux experts en écriture lui ont
attribué les lettres du corbeau c'était
hier aujourd'hui il était question de
son emploi du temps le 16 octobre le
jour de la disparition de grégory
dominique verdeilhan givre à gries à la
sortie de l'audience d'hier soir
christine villemin présenter un visage
fermé et sombre
rien à dire rien à répondre la réponse
est dans son regard
bien qu'installé sur le banc des témoins
christine villemin a bien compris qu'il
se retrouvait en position d'accusé
comment 85 sommes à la veille de son
inculpation et de son incarcération
loin des jurés christine villemin essuie
ses larmes
je n'ai écrit aucune lettre j'entends
les experts dire que leur travail les a
rendus malades pendant trois jours
- ça fait neuf ans que je suis malade et
dans 20 ans je serai encore montré du
doigt accusés d'avoir tué mon enfant ce
matin même pas tim même appréhension
perceptible sur le visage de christine
villemin remises au premier plan de la
faire elle compte sur la protection de
ses avocats
cette même patick cette même
appréhension sont visibles sur le visage
de jean marie villemin filmer ce matin
même avant la reprise de l'audience à la
barre son épouse revit la disparition de
grégory
la voix est tremblotante c'était un
enfant farceur espiègle je me suis
demandé s'il ne se cachait pas vers
21h30
jean marie m'a pris dans ses bras et m'a
dit titi est mort il m'a allongé sur le
canapé
il y avait un médecin à côté de moi
après je ne me souviens plus les jeux
ont donc le choix entre deux visages
celui que dessine par extension les
expert en graphologie celui d'un corbeau
en puissance et celui que présente à la
barre christine villemin
elle même ce n'est pas moi qui ai tué
mon enfant j'adorais grégory à la colère
d'une femme suspectés ont succédé ce
matin les larmes d'une mère innocenté
par un non lieu